that's Howard Schultz campaign is gonna
be a real grind day man I wonder if he's
gonna get roasted quick quiz what's the
biggest political party in the United
States right now
oh wait that long
time's up did you say independence
because if you didn't well you then are
wrong according to Gallup which has been
tracking which political party people
identify with for decades 39% of people
in January 2019 call themselves
independents while 34% said they were
Democrats and 25% identified as
Republicans now while that independent
number is down from 45% who called
themselves independents in March 2018
it's still pretty remarkable right more
people think of themselves as
unaffiliated with either major party
then identify with Republicans or
Democrats it's even the sort of number
that might encourage you to run for
president as an independent in 2020 if
you were and I'm spitballing here simply
minded ambitious and very very rich
which is where Howard Schultz comes in
you might not know Schultz his name or
face yet but you have likely consumed
lots and lots of his delicious Java chip
frappuccinos over your lifetime Schultz
is the former chairman and CEO of
Starbucks he stepped down from that job
last year and has been seen ever since
as a potential presidential candidate
now in mid-january in an interview with
60 minutes Schultz made very clear that
he's not only likely to run for
president but he's going to do so as an
independent we're living at a most
fragile time not only the fact that this
president is not qualified to be the
president but the fact that both parties
are consistently not doing what's
necessary on behalf of the American
people and aren't engaged every single
day in revenge politics all of which
sounds good
people are sick of politics as usual and
they do hate Washington
and everyone in it less than three and
ten people in a recent NBC Wall Street
Journal poll said they thought the
country was currently heading in the
right direction just 39 percent approved
of President Donald Trump how about
Nancy Pelosi's approval you ask how does
twenty eight percent approval for the
speaker sound so we should just coronate
I mean elect elect Schulz president now
right not so fast there are lots of
problems with running for president as
an independent which probably explains
why we haven't had an independent
president yet and why Schulz is unlikely
to break that forever trend let's go
through the problems problem number one
the two parties are super powerful did
you know every state has a different
process to qualify for the presidential
ballot they do all 50 and do you know
that most of those states require you to
collect lots and lots of signatures from
people who live in them and that
collecting tens of thousands of
signatures is hugely labor-intensive and
very very expensive but when you're the
democratic or Republican nominee for
president the long-standing party
infrastructure handles all of that for
you when you're running as an
independent
not so much problem number two there are
fewer actual independents out there than
you might think
now remember all those numbers I cited
about how there are more independents in
the country than there are Democrats or
Republicans yeah they're basically bunk
nextly they're not totally bunk just not
totally accurate when it comes to who
people vote for when they choose a
presidential candidate people love to
tell pollsters that their independence
because it fits with how they see
themselves they aren't reflexively
partisan rather than looking at which
party someone comes from they instead
make a recent assessment of which
candidates policies are better for the
country except that voting patterns tell
us that is almost never true and truth
about so-called independence is that
most of them are closeted partisans yeah
they like to tell pollsters and people
like cocktail parties that they don't
side with one party but when they vote
they consistently vote for one side over
the other problem number three you have
to convince people you aren't just a
spoiler a quick look at Schultz's
Twitter feed since he announced he was
likely to run for president as an
independent reveals this Democrats
really and I mean really don't want him
to do it the argument goes that Schulz
all lifetime Democrat will sap votes
from the Democratic nominee and lower
Trump's win number in a two way race
Trump needs fifty percent of the vote
plus one which most polls suggest he
will struggle to come anywhere close to
in a 3-way race however Trump could win
somewhere between 42 percent and 47
percent depending on how credible
Schultz remains in the race the other
less partisan problem with the whole
spoiler thing is that the average voter
doesn't like to feel like they are
throwing their vote away on someone who
has zero chance of winning there's a
long history of independent candidates
running in the mid teens in terms of
support a few months before the election
and then watching that support totally
collapse as the election gets closer and
people think twice about casting what
amounts to a protest vote of course none
of this means Schultz won't run I mean
he's running unless something huge and
unforeseen happens and none of it means
that he can't be a real factor in the
race especially if Democrats choose
someone regarded as too far to the
ideological left of the average swing
voter what all of it means though is
this running as an independent for
president and wanting to actually have a
chance to win is a hell of a lot harder
than it looks from a quick analysis of
our country's politics
and that is the point we make new
episodes every week check back every
Tuesday and Thursday for the latest and
greatest in political videos